ever since I saw the movie limitless
starring Bradley Cooper I've been
obsessed with the idea of using your
brain to its fullest potential
more specifically the ability to
remember everything you have ever
learned and be able to communicate that
information quickly effectively and
charmingly so after years of trying to
make myself limitless and chasing this
peak mental performance I've discovered
that some of the most effective things
that will help you get there are
actually simple daily habits you can
start implementing right away so let's
just cut to the chase here are five
habits that you can start implementing
today that will help you become
limitless in real life tip number one is
learn broadly and thoroughly what I mean
by that is don't just read
self-improvement books if you want to be
somebody who has just a mass of useful
relevant information you have to expand
your horizons read books about the Cold
War Bitcoin the stock exchange
ancient civilizations start getting some
hands-on experience with repairing
vehicles repairing electronics cooking
good food by really pushing yourself to
expand the subjects that you learn not
only is that useful for you in your own
life but people will start looking at
you like you're the most interesting man
in the world the second part of this tip
is to learn thoroughly they say that you
only need to read three books in a
particular subject to know more about
that subject than 99% of the population
although this isn't concrete science it
makes sense a lot of people in this day
and age don't have the patience or focus
to get through one book from beginning
to end let alone three books so if
you're someone who read three books on a
particular subject you'll be an expert
in that subject compared to most people
on the planet also when you read these
books make sure to pay attention don't
be multitasking as you're reading you
might even want to bring a highlighter
or a pencil or if you don't wanna mark
up your book bring a notepad so you
could write down some of your thoughts
on a chapter you just read if you want
to become limitless reading isn't just
an activity to pass the time you're
trying to soak in useful information
that you can use in the future for when
it's relevant and if you're one of those
people who sucks at reading or can't
focus on reading books I made a whole
video about how to read when you hate
reading the link is in the description
it also happens to be my most popular
video so
tip number two is to talk to somebody
about the things you were learning and
the books you were reading so for the
longest time I'm talking several years I
was trying to teach myself how to be
conversational in Spanish but every time
I talked to somebody who actually knew
conversational Spanish I mean the
biggest fool of myself but that all
changed in university when I took two
semesters of Spanish and it wasn't
because I spent a long time with my nose
pressed in a book memorizing vocabulary
because I've done that before
but the biggest game-changer was these
conversation times that we had two to
three times a week in Spanish in which
the professor forced us for 20 or 30
minutes each lesson to implement all the
vocabulary and new things we learned
into our conversations with our
classmates as soon as the conversation
went stale we switched classmates and we
just talked and talked and talked and
talked and this process of soaking in
information thinking about it and then
trying to use it in real life is
integral that is the full learning
process if you just do step one you're
just read and read and read and read
it'll stay in your head and it will
never come out so if you really want to
be somebody who is just overflowing with
useful information you have to practice
not only the input of information but
also the output of information this is
as easy as just talking to a friend for
30 or 40 seconds about a drink coffee or
something like that just be like hey
I've been reading this book and there's
a concept in it that I find really
fascinating and it is this and hopefully
if you have a friend who's willing to
actually talk about interesting ideas
that'll spark a conversation and you can
further reflect on the information and
form new ideas around it you can also
join a book club or Toastmasters just
anything that'll help you communicate
the information that you're putting in
number three is learn to meditate now if
you're somebody who still hasn't tried
meditation or you're kind of weirded out
because you think it's some sort of
Eastern Zen kind of something to do with
chakras and spirit animals and stuff
like that that is not how meditation has
to be and my version of meditation is
almost like a breathing exercise it's
more like a tool that helps me focus
the longer the day goes on I get
completely scatterbrained I'm such a
multitasker and I think of a million
things in an
different directions all at once so if
I'm presented with a book or one single
video editing task or something like
that it's very hard for me to focus on
that one thing because my brain is just
everywhere the way I collect myself is
by this very simple meditation that I do
I just set a timer for five minutes
doesn't have to take forever close my
eyes I breathe in and out very slowly
for five minutes and I focus all my
attention on my breath I just bring all
of my consciousness into my body instead
of my mind that way when the five
minutes is up I'm no longer scattered
I'm just in one place and I can use that
super collective state of mind to dive
into the tasks that I need to dive into
my attention is now completely on that
thing
just does wonders for the input and
output of information tip number four is
to reduce the living hell out of social
media and bad screen time I love
technology I'm a filmmaker pretty much
all my purchases are electronics but
when it comes to social media I'm a lot
more skeptical especially something like
Instagram when you have a discover feed
or Facebook with a you know main news
feed or something like that when you're
endlessly scrolling through the explore
page on Instagram you're practically
turning your rational brain off and your
primal brain on and you become sort of
this entity who only responds to what
will give him the biggest dopamine rush
like a hot girl or somebody getting
whipped in the back with a pool noodle I
can't think of one good reason to enter
into that kind of state it's completely
useless and it makes focusing on more
complex tasks really difficult social
media is a great tool for communication
and getting messages across I use social
media all the time but I really really
try to limit any time on the explore
page anytime where I'm just kind of
turning my brain off and becoming a
stimulus sponge so by limiting bad
screen time like this all the previous
tips will be a lot easier to do tip
number five is to take care of your body
this includes things like going to bed
at a good
or waking up at a good time staying
hydrated eating well getting exercise
your brain is an organ in the body so
what's good for the body is also good
for the brain there's no point in
practicing the previous four tips unless
you get this one right because what good
is putting information into an
information machine if that machine is
rusty ill maintained and smells like
Doritos I cover a lot of these health
tips in my previous video about how to
have more energy so check that out if
you want to find ways to make your
information machine more efficient more
effective and more limitless so guys
that's it by following these five tips
your brain will be sharper than ever
before your brain will be bubbling with
useful information and people all across
the world will look at you like you're
just so smart so intelligent and so hot
if you like this video be sure to hit
that like button if you like videos like
these in general hit that subscribe
button once you hit that subscribe
button hit that Bell icon because if you
subscribe and don't hit that Bell icon
you probably won't get a notification
that I uploaded a new video and I want
to hear from you guys so like drop what
book you read last or what book you're
reading down in the comment section
below also I only made this video
because you guys voted on it in the
Facebook page so if you're not already
part of the Facebook page click the link
in the description right now go ahead
and follow that page and you'll have
voting power that's all for today thank
you for watching and we'll catch you the
next video
actually that's that's it for b-roll
today